content platforms treat the content on
your website or app like data in the
beginning we had html websites where
content was embedded directly in the
code but that was never going to scale
well the next generation of websites
used a content management system or cms
where content is stored in a database
then injected into an html template this
works great until you decide you want to
migrate your app into a fancy new
javascript framework or maybe you want
to display the same content on ios palm
os and android or you may just have
multiple views for the same content
within a single application these
demands gave rise to the headless cms a
tool that turns your content into a
cloud-based api so it can be accessed
from any application today a content
platform is a critical layer of the
modern tech stack where it serves as a
single source of truth for your brand
and because it's completely decoupled
from your application code and user
database you can take it with you
anywhere in addition it gives you the
ability to model and custom tailor your
content for any situation rather than
start from a cookie cutter solution you
can build your own schema with different
fields for things like text and images
and create relationships between items
like you might in a relational database
it's a win for marketers because they
have a single polished interface for
managing content but it's an even bigger
win for us developers because we can now
query content from any code base in a
consistent and structured way one tool
that makes that possible is sanity a
popular choice for jam stack
applications which stands for javascript
apis and markup sanity is part of the a
and the jam stack it provides an open
source studio where you can model your
content with javascript and manage it in
the browser meanwhile the actual data is
stored in the cloud in what's known as a
content lake which can then be queried
from a friend application quickly with
its built-in ctn while supporting
features like graphql web hooks and
real-time updates this has been content
platforms in 100 seconds but stay tuned
because today i've invited cap from
sanity to take us beyond 100 seconds and
show us exactly how a content platform
can fit into our tech stack
thank you so much for that intro aloha
everyone my name is cap and i do
developer relations at
sanity.io so sanity is a platform for
structured content as a content platform
sanity helps you manage and deliver your
content in ways you may have not thought
possible if you're thinking of adding a
content platform to your project look no
further than this fully customizable
sanity project product i'm about to show
you so content can be a lot of different
things it can be
the content for a blog or a portfolio it
could be the video content on a course
platform it could be the menu and the
hours and the address of a restaurant
it could be a car manufacturer's content
and the number of cars that were made in
a quarter how many were sent out and how
many were purchased
it could be the music tracks for a
singer and they're trying to get their
name out in the world so they want to
save it all in one spot
it could be the times and winners for
each sporting event and a major
tournament you get the picture content
is everywhere and we can find it all
online within a couple of seconds
so with most projects
content is going to be present it's best
to manage it and know where content is
going from the beginning incorporating a
content platform saves you time in the
long run
but there are many other benefits too
and let me tell you about those so a
content platform should allow you
freedom with your content one of the
biggest reasons why most developers or
content creators hesitate to incorporate
a content platform is that there's this
fear of losing true ownership to your
content to your stuff
a content platform should not steal
ownership it should allow you to own it
of course it's yours it should allow you
to deliver your content however and
wherever you need it to go it should
also allow you to structure and manage
it however it best fits your needs
so let me show you how with sanity you
can accomplish all of those things
built with react there is a sanity.io
backend ui for the content called sanity
studio the studio is fully customizable
you structure your content or your data
however you need and because it's built
with react if you know react you can
code it up to be however you want it to
look
and then there's a nifty thing called
portable text portable text is storing
your rich text in json format
that json format can be reused
everywhere
mobile desktop a different front end etc
more on that in a little
so we should be treating our content as
data and because our content is data we
want to treat it as such so wherever you
need your data to go or do with sanity
the possibilities are nearly endless
using sanity allows for full
customization of how your structure
content looks for editors developers
anyone manipulating the content
it also allows for the ability to
reshape and present your content in any
format
so using sanity and the content like you
now have a real-time database that gives
you access to your content however and
wherever you need
you know how
you redesign your website every couple
of months just because
or you want to try that new framework
with structured content you can redesign
you can try a new framework at any time
so go ahead use that new javascript
framework and continue using your
content like you've been doing
so let me show you how with sanity.io to
get a project up and running in just a
few minutes remember what i show you
today can be used on any front end i'll
show you how to spin up a project and
also a couple other cool things to get
you going right out of the box so let's
go ahead and let's structure our content
all right so to get started go to
sanity.io here we're going to find these
two buttons get started get started
click on either one of these
so once we click on that we'll see
official starters you can choose one of
these but we're actually going to do
this npm install so we're going to be
installing globally this sanity cli and
we're going to be running the command
sanity init that will start our very own
sanity project so what i did is i copied
that command
and
i now went to my terminal and in my
terminal i'm going to paste that command
in
hit enter and then it will install the
cli for me and it will initialize a
brand new project
if you have not logged in using sanity
on your local computer you will be
prompted you may be prompted to log in
using either google github or email
password choose one of those remember
what you choose because we're going to
need that in the future
so i'm going to create new project i'll
hit enter
and we're going to name our project so
this is whatever you want it to be named
whatever you want your sanity project to
be named i'm going to name it fireship
so i'm going to hit enter
and then we are going to be asked about
the data set so we are going to be using
the default data set so i'm just going
to hit y for yes it will be called
production so we're going to want that
is that path correct it is so i'm going
to hit enter
now we can choose from movie e-commerce
blog or clean project
we are going to do blog for this one the
other ones have like
uh so they'll have like pre-built
schemas
with um some data in it the blog one is
a pre-built schema with no data in it
and then the clean one of course has
nothing so you would just build your own
schemas out
with this one we don't want any
pre-built data we just want pre-built
schemas
and it is done all right so we're going
to cd into our project
and now we are in it we can run other
either sanity docs manage help any of
those but we actually want to open this
up in our text editor of choice so i'm
going to actually open it in vs code
there's a shortcut that i have installed
code space period if you have that use
that if not go to your vs code or text
editor and open yours up
now i'm going to make this big
all right so let's go through a little
bit of this file structure so the
sanity.json if we go here we actually
can find our project id and the name of
it so we named it fireship
we have that
this project id is what you will need
if you need something else to speak to
your content link so say you have your
react front end
or your next js front end and you want
it to speak to this
data set then you will need this project
id so that is an easy way to find it now
i also want to point out the schemas
folder in here if we did the clean
project when we were
answering those questions this would
pretty much be empty just a couple
things would be in here but like author
category post those would not be here
now if we went to schema.js
here's where we import and use all of
our different schema files
so we have block content category post
author that also matches up with all
these over here and then down here
is when we use it
so we import it and then use it
if you make a new file make sure you
come in here and import and use
now i'm going to go to post
this is our document type now sanity
uses schema types and in schema types
document is one of them there's also
string
slug
reference image and we'll go through a
couple of these and i'll show you what
they look like
this one is a our document type post and
it has an array
of fields so there's title there's slug
but let me actually just show you what
this looks like on the browser side on
the sanity studio
front-end side the ui side of it so i'm
going to open up my uh terminal
i used ctrl tilde to open it up within
vs code you can open it up however you
want and i'm going to run the command
sanity start so run that command hit
enter
and it's starting up our studio
and it will live at localhost 3333 so
it's ready let's go back to our browser
localhost 3333
and here remember whatever you chose
when you did the login at the beginning
choose here
so i'm going to do google
and
i am now authorized so because it is
mine i have authorization to it
if you want to give someone else
authorization to it go to
manage.sanity.io
and you can add more users
so this is what our studio looks like it
has the name you can search through your
content desk vision we'll get to the
vision plugin in a little bit but here
are our three document types so post
nothing let's actually add a new post
so
let's do my first blog post
we will generate a slug
author
is
let me pull this down
author is a
reference
it's referencing
this author document so before we
actually
can see anything in this drop down we
need to go make an author so we can
leave all this here i'm gonna go back to
content click on author and let's make
sure i'm gonna click on this little
pencil
i'm going to make a new author we'll
just do my name
generate
and
i
am cap
and then publish that
awesome so now that's published let's go
back to our post
back to the one that we were working on
and if i do the drop down we now see
that author i just made if we had a
picture if i had added a picture to that
this would be the little thumbnail of
that picture
then we have main image
and let's add a main image then we have
categories publish that and body
so with main image let me actually make
this just a little bit smaller
main image there are three ways
to upload a main image you can click on
upload and it will bring down the file
structure like the files from your own
computer you can drop in an image so
just like drag and drop or you can paste
in an image and we're going to do that
so i'm going to go to unsplash
and let's look up
cats
we'll do this cat with the butterfly so
we're going to copy image
go back here and i'm going to do command
v to paste it in and now we have
our cat and butterfly image
and
there we go now let me show you a really
cool thing about
sanity and images so i just unzoom this
a little bit more because i need to show
you everything that's going on
but if i click on edit details
in here
i have
some views of my image
so this is a really cool thing about
sanity is i upload once and it will work
for all these aspect ratios
i can crop here and this is the crop
and i can do hotspot
hot spot is making sure let me actually
show you the thumbnail as i'm doing it
so hot spot is making sure that whatever
is in this hot spot is always in view no
matter what type of aspect ratio my
image is so if i want to make sure that
the cat's
ear is always in view notice how the
panorama changed
or if i want the cat's nose always in
view notice how it's changing
so i don't have to do
um like multiple uploads to make sure
that my that my crop is good that my hot
spot's always on
sanity will make sure that this spot
that your hot spot is on is always in
view
and that's how that works
so then you just exit out and there's my
hot spot and crop for my image
so here is the body of my first blog
post
now
this is the rich text editor and in here
we'll live our portable text
here is
the body of my blog
post
i hope you like it old-fashioned smiley
face
and so here is our portable text
portable text will live in this rich
text editor and
this is the sanity way of storing our
rich text
so you know how when you get html and
you want to put it into react
application
it kind of
isn't very intuitive because you have to
do
the dangerously set prop and then you
kind of lose control of it so because
portable text is data it becomes json
and so you can actually put it into your
react application it makes it more
intuitive as you pass it along to
mobile to desktop to
react to view
if you want to use a native app and
you're using html it would be harder
json
would make it easier and this is saved
as a json format
so this means that you can now query for
your content so say you wanted to find
out all the blog posts that had
code blocks in it you can do that
because all of this is stored as data
your content is your data and
that is portable text
now let me actually show you so here's
our first blog post let's publish it
let me actually show you
the inspect to our blog post if you
click on those three dots click on
inspect here is all of the json of our
blog post we have our main image we have
the title
we have all of our rich text
so that is how it looks that's how it's
sort and this is how we can query for it
things like this all right so let me
show you a really cool feature about
main image i know we already had hotspot
on crop
but let me show you another thing so if
i go to my vision plugin wait before i
do that i actually have to go to the
three dots
inspect
and i need to find my main image
reference
this is the id to my image so i'm going
to copy that
so under my main image the asset ref
i'm going to come to my vision plugin
now the vision plug-in this is where we
can query for our own content
we're going to use grok today
you can use either graphql or grok with
sanity grok is an in-house sanity made
query language and i will show you how
it's done just a little bit there are
definitely more places that you can
learn about grok
but yeah let me start off
so by doing the asterisk i am grabbing
all of my content link i'm going to do
the square brackets to filter down so
i'm going to do underscore id is equal
to and i'm going to paste in the id that
i grabbed from the image
okay i'm going to run that query and in
here this is all of the content we get
back from that image so create it at
the id of it the id will match what we
just had over here
the type
but i really want to point this part out
so under the metadata we get dimensions
but we also get the palette
this palette is pretty awesome in here
we get our
dark muted dark vibrant light vibrant
muted all the colors that are part of
this image and a
optimal foreground color for it
so dark vibrant
takes up 1.93 of the image
this is the color and this would be a
good foreground color for it so if you
put text over this part of the image
it would be really great for
accessibility this color for the text
let's look at
light vibrant
so it takes up that much of the image
this is the color and this would be a
good foreground color so that's just a
really awesome thing to
to note
that you can have that you have this at
your fingertips with all the images so
you can find that go to your vision plug
plugin query for that id and you have
all this at your fingertips so really
great
okay so let's actually add a couple
things to our studio so we have what it
comes with but let's add a couple things
so i'm going to go back to my code
and under title within the post.js file
in the schemas folder let's go
underneath here and type in description
and we'll do
keep titles
short and sweet
let's do a smiley face
save that
and if we go back
keep titles short and sweet so it's just
a quick little description that you can
have
and you can start customizing your
studio
but let's create a whole new schema type
so if we go to
the schema types in the docs for sanity
we will find
an entire list of all of the schema
types that we can use
so we've been working in document
we've done the string we have done image
let's
add a number
so if we go to number is what it will
look like
and there's the properties there's
options
and then invalidation
but here's what we need for our schema
so i'm going to copy that
take it over
let's do it right after this
the slug
add a comma to separate those objects
and let's change the title so we just
need the title name and type
for our
new schema type so title will do time
time to read
that is the title that will live within
our studio so this is the title this is
the title
the name is the name of the field
time to read
type will keep as number i'm going to
save that
come back here and now we have
a brand new time to read notice how
these little arrows come up i could add
that way
or i could edit
this way so let's actually add a
validation let's make sure that you
can't do longer than
20 minutes time to read okay
so i'm going to come up here and these
are all the different types of
validations we can do required min
number less than
let's learn more about validation and if
we come down here
we want this line so validation and i'll
actually just go just to required
because we want required
i'm going to copy that line
go back to my number
and paste that in
and then let's also add the less than
[Music]
20.
so
no matter what we can't make the number
go above 20 otherwise we'll get a
warning
come back here and last number we put in
was 88 and sure enough
it's giving us an error must be less
than 20. so no matter what if we just
keep going down
until we get it below 20
it's not gonna be happy with this 19
and if i go up error again so if you
want 20 to be included
then we would change this to 21
and we don't get the error but the
moment we go go up we get that error
again so that is a validation rule to
make sure that it stays within the
numbers that you want
all right so now that that's all done
let's publish that
and let's get our
sanity studio deployed
so what we need to do is we need to go
back to our code
and in here i'm going to keep this
i'm going to create a new one and we
need to run the command sanity deploy
hit enter
now studio host name this is now unique
so
when you created the project with me you
could have used the name fireship
alongside me because that's local but
this one is unique i am going to use the
name fireship see if that's available
and it looks like it
is
because it's not giving me an error so
now fire ship is now taken so you can't
use that and by the time you're watching
this maybe fire ship one and fire ship
two are also taken so it has to be
unique
and once it is done my studio will now
live at fireship.sanity.studio
and i will have i will have
authorization to view it and anyone else
i give authorization can view it so
there's my new url
come back here fireship.sanity.studio
and here is
my
newly deployed
studio with all my stuff first blog post
everything that i have now let me show
you a really cool thing i'm gonna
shrink this a little bit
pull this one out
and now i have my local one version my
local version running and i have my
deployed version running
now these two
are the same studio
but watch this
so anything i do in my local version
shows up in my
deployed version anything i do in my
deployed version shows up in my local
version
and if i do anything
you can see these little pencils show up
on both sides if i click on that little
pencil it will show what has happened
and we can see who made that change and
if i come over here
click on review changes
we can revert that change from either
side
revert that change we don't want it and
it disappears
so that is live preview insanity to see
both the local side and the deployed
side working together live
and if i publish
will be published on both sides and
yeah
and that is how you build your first
project with sanity.io
all right so we have our own content
like up and running that we can query
against we have the json for all of our
content and the content can be used
across all platforms we're not limited
to anything so thank you so much for
watching if you have more questions
about content platforms or about sanity
you can find me on twitter at kapeh
underscore okay or you can find an
entire sanity slack community at
slack.sanity.io thank you so much for
watching and i'll see you around